una nueva muestra de ira por más de un
año de crisis económica y seis meses de
parálisis política por séptimo día
consecutivo los manifestantes quemaron
neumáticos para bloquear las principales
carreteras de líbano hemos dicho varias
veces y repetimos que habrá una escalada
porque no creo que el estado esté
haciendo nada y la gente no solo tiene
hambre sino tiene muchas demandas la
crisis económica que estalló en 2019
llevó a miles de personas a las calles
exigiendo la renuncia del gobierno la
pandemia y la explosión del puerto de
beirut en 2020 sólo agravaron la
situación la pasada semana el valor de
la libra libanesa cayó en un nuevo
mínimo histórico lo que llevó nuevamente
a la ciudadanía a las calles decenas de
miles de empleos se han perdido cuentas
han sido congeladas y el hambre se hace
cada vez más común en la escena del 17
de octubre de 2019 tiene que repetirse y
nos quedaremos en las calles a partir de
hoy serán abiertas ojalá todos se unen a
nosotros para mostrar al mundo entero
que todos estamos unidos que todos
tenemos reivindicaciones que todos
sufrimos y que queremos un cambio el
nuevo primer ministro designado saad
al-hariri acusa al presidente michel aún
de bloquear los avances para formar un
nuevo gobierno en medio de una parálisis
política líbano no logra llevar a cabo
reformas exigidas por la comunidad
internacional para desbloquear miles de
millones de dólares de ayuda